♪ GO AHEAD AND TELL EVERYBODY
♪ I'M THE MAN.
>> Jesse: EXCUSES, EXCUSES, VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS DISHING
UP PLENTY OF BLAME AND REASONS
ON WHY SHE HASN'T VISITED THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
33 DAYS SINCE PRESIDENT BIDEN
APPOINTED HER AS THE CRISIS
POINT PERSON.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO GO THERE.
>> YES.
WE ARE WORKING ON THE PLAN TO
GET INTEREST.  WE HAVE DEAL WITH
COVID ISSUES.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE SOLVED
OVERNIGHT.
IT'S A COMPLEX ISSUE.
LISTEN, IF THIS WERE EASY, IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN HANDLED YEARS
AGO.
WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS.
BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO EVIDENCE
ITSELF OVERNIGHT.
IT WILL NOT.
BUT IT WILL BE WORTH IT.
>> Jesse: BUT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE KNOW EXACTLY WHO IS TO
BLAME.
VOTERS IN A NEW FOX POLL SAYS
BORDER SECURITY IS WORSE TODAY
THAN TWO YEARS AGO.
GUESS WHAT IS MAKING AN
APPEARANCE AT THE BORDER?
COPIES OF THE VP'S 2019
CHILDREN'S BOOK HANDED OUT TO
KIDS AT A SHELTER ALONG THE
SOUTHERN BORDER IN CALIFORNIA.
HARRIS' OFFICE SAYING THEY
WEREN'T AWARE OF THESE WELCOME
PACKS AND THAT THEY ARE USUALLY
ORGANIZED BY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY.
WOW, DANA, IMAGINE IF TRUMP GAVE
ART OF THE DEAL TO KIDS IN
CAGES, I JUST CANNOT -- I CAN'T
EVEN SEE WHAT THEY WOULD SAY
ABOUT THAT.
I DON'T KNOW.
TAKEN DEIGN MAKE IT A COLORING
PECULIAR.
>> Jesse: SILLY WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT IT WHAT DO YOU THINK IS
GOING ON HERE?
>> Dana: I'M REALLY JUST
SURPRISED AT ALL OF THIS.
I WILL TELL YOU WHY.
SO, IF YOU RECALL, VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS WAS GIVEN
THIS -- MADE THE POINT PERSON ON
THE BORDER THE DAY AFTER SHE
LAUGHED AT A QUESTION WHEN SHE
WAS ASKED ABOUT GOING TO THE
BORDER.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THEY
OVERCORRECTED ON A P.R. ISSUE
THAT THEY COULD HAVE HANDLED AND
NOW THEY HAVE MUCH BIGGER.
R ISSUE BECAUSE SHE CLEARLY
DOESN'T REALLY WANT TO DEAL WITH
THIS.
WHEN THEY SAY THAT, YOU KNOW,
SUPER HEROS ARE EVERYWHERE BUT
THEY ARE NOT AT THE BORDER
APPARENTLY BECAUSE THIS ISSUE TO
ME, A VICE PRESIDENT WOULD, ONE,
WANT TO TAKE ON A BIG ISSUE LIKE
THIS AND ALSO THE ADMINISTRATION
IS TAKING ON SO MUCH WATER AND
NEGATIVITY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
BORDER ISSUE AS YOU SAW IN THAT
POLL AND THEN ALL THE OTHER
POLLS.
IT'S JUST OBVIOUS ON ITS FACE.
I'M STARTING TO FEEL LIKE, YOU
KNOW, SHE HAD THIS MOMENT INS
THESE FIRST 100 DAYS AND IT WAS
DIFFERENT AND IT WAS NEW.
WHEN YOU SEE ON WEDNESDAY NIGHT
WHEN SHE IS SITTING THERE WITH
NANCY PELOSI AND BIDEN IS GIVING
THE SPEECH, THAT WILL BE
HISTORIC, THAT IS A MOMENT.
BUT THEN WHAT ARE YOU DOING WITH
THAT MOMENT?
WHERE ARE YOU STEPPING UP?
I FEEL LIKE -- I JUST REALLY
FEEL THAT THAT HAS BEEN LACKING.
>> Jesse: WELL, DAGEN, SHE SAYS
SHE CAN'T GET DOWN TO THE
NORTHERN TRIANGLE BECAUSE OF
COVID.
SHE HAS BEEN VACCINATED.
I'M SURE THE PRESIDENTS OF THOSE
COUNTRIES HAVE BEEN VACCINATED
THAT'S NOW JUST A CONVENIENCE
EXCUSE.
WILL.
>> Dagen: WHAT MESSAGE DOES THAT
SEND TO THE BORDER PERSONNEL AND
THE VOLUNTEERS AT THE BORDER AND
WELL, QUITE FRANKLY, PEOPLE
WORKING IN HOSPITALS FOR MORE
THAN THE LAST YEAR AND GROCERY
STORE WORKERS WHO PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE.
THIS IS A LOSE-LOSE FOR VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS IN TWO WAYS
BECAUSE SHE IS CLEARLY BEING FED
THIS OH BLAME COVID, DON'T GO TO
THE BORDER YET.
AND THEN THESE BOOKS MAGICALLY
SHOW UP IN WELCOME GIFT BAGS FOR
CHILDREN.
SO THAT MAKES HER LIKE -- LOOKS
LIKE SHE IS NOT IN CHARGE.
SO SHE IS WEEK OR, ON THE OTHER
HAND, SHE JUST DOESN'T WANT TO
BE PHOTOGRAPHED WITH A BUNCH OF
SUFFERING CHILDREN AND THAT
MAKES HER LOOK UNCARING.
SO SHE CAN'T GET OUT OF THIS.
BUT THEY ARE CRAVING -- THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION THEY ARE
CRAVEN POLL WATCHERS IF THESE
NUMBERS KEEP DECLINING THEY WILL
MAKE A CHANGE AND FAST.
REMEMBER WHAT THEY DID LAST
SUMMER?
THEY DIDN'T SAY BUTKUS ABOUT THE
RIOTS THAT WERE RAGING IN CITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND THEY ONLY
SPOKE OUT ABOUT IT AFTER THE
POLL NUMBERS STARTED MOVING
AGAINST THEM.
>> Jesse: THAT IS TRUE.
JUAN, I HAVE TO GIVE CREDIT
WHERE CREDIT IS DUE.
BIDEN SAW THIS COMING AND HE
SAID HERE, KAMALA, YOU
ON KAMALA HARRIS TAKING WATER
AND BIDEN SITTING AT 1600, YOU
KNOW, CHEWING GUM OR DOING
WHATEVER IS HE DOING.
>> Juan: WELL, NO, I THINK WHAT
WE SAW IN THE POLL NUMBERS
INDICATED THAT IMMIGRATION IS A
REAL PROBLEM FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
HE IS THE PRESIDENT, JESSE.
AND IS HE GETTING HIT ON THAT
SUBJECT.
I MEAN, HE HAS GOT TO COME UP
WITH SOME IDEAS.
NOW, I DON'T BUY INTO THIS IDEA
THAT IT SIMPLY IS MAKING A PHOTO
OP. AT THE BORDER.
IS THE KEY TO THE SOLUTION.
GOSH, IF THAT'S THE CASE THEN
SENATOR CRUZ, SENATOR LANGUAGES
FORD, I THINK CONGRESSMAN
McCARTHY THEY HAVE BEEN DOWN
AT THE BORDER WE DON'T HAVE A
SOLUTION AS A RESULT OF THEIR
MAGICAL PHOTO OP. TAKING
SELFIES.
>> Jesse: WE DO.
>> Juan: TRYING TO EXPLOIT THE
ISSUE FOR POLITICAL ADVANTAGE.
I THINK THAT THE REALITY IS, YOU
KNOW, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE STEPS
THAT THEY ARE TAKING, THE KAMALA
HARRIS AND PRESIDENT BIDEN ARE
TAKING, I THINK THEY ARE REAL
STEPS.
THEY ARE TRYING TO IMPROVE
BORDER SECURITY AND YOU HAVE
SEEN THE ARREST, THE
APPREHENSIONS UP MARKEDLY, YOU
HAVE SEEN IMPROVEMENT IN TERMS
OF THE ASYLUM PROCESS WITH MORE
JUDGES PUT IN PLACE SO THAT IT
CAN BE MORE SPEEDY.
YOU SEE INCREASED COOPERATION
NOW COMING FROM MEXICO AND I
THINK THAT'S A BREAK THROUGH.
YOU ALSO SEE THEM TRYING TO
ESTABLISH PROCESSING PLACES FOR
PEOPLE WHO WANT ASYLUM.
REFUGEES WHO ARE SEEKING ASYLUM
IN THEIR HOME COUNTRIES.
THEY ARE OUTSIDE THE UNITED
STATES.
BUT I THINK THE BIG THING IS
GIVING AID TO SOME OF THESE
COUNTRIES AND SAYING PEOPLE
DON'T WANT TO LEAVE HOME.
THEY WOULD RATHER STAY.
BUT THEY ARE SUFFERING FROM, YOU
KNOW, VIOLENCE, ECONOMIC
DEVASTATION, TORNADOES AND THE
LIKE.
LET'S LOOK AT THIS REALISTICALLY
AND I THINK YOU TAKE GRADUAL
STEPS.
>> Jesse: WELL, REALISTICALLY WE
HAVE BEEN GIVING AID FOR YEARS
AND THAT HASN'T ALWAYS WORK.
GREG, I WOULD HAVE GIVEN THE
PLUS TO THESE KIDS COMING ACROSS
THAT WILL GET THEM STARTED HERE.
>> Greg: ABSOLUTELY, THEY WOULD
LEARN SO MUCH MORE.
BY THE WAY, I DO AGREE WITH
JUAN, APPREHENSION IS UP ON THE
BORDER.
AND MEXICO WAS ALREADY
COOPERATING WITH AMERICA.
IT WASN'T A BREAK THROUGH.
TRUMP ALREADY HAD THAT COVERED.
WE ALSO LEARNED HOW TO DO THOSE
PHOTO OP.S FROM AOC WHO WAS DOWN
AT THE BORDER CRYING HER EYES
OUT IF YOU REMEMBER THAT.
I THINK THIS WHOLE THING WAS A
DESPERATE PLOY TO IT GET
DESPERATE SECURITY FOR A NEW
BOOK.
SHE COULDN'T GET BOOK SIGNING AT
BORDERS SO SHE WENT TO THE
BORDER.
THAT IS A JOKE ABOUT A BOOKSTORE
THAT NO LONGER EXISTS FOR YOU
YOUNG PEOPLE.
HERE IS THE INTERESTING STORY I
DIDN'T SEE THIS COMING.
SHE IS REVEALING HERSELF IT BE
NOT VERY GOOD AT THIS, NOT VERY
GOOD AT THIS JOB IN GENERAL.
THIS COULD BE WHY SHE FAILED
MISERABLY IN THE PRIMARY BECAUSE
SHE WAS THE MEDIA'S PICK NOT THE
PEOPLE'S PICK I PICKED HER.
I THOUGHT SHE WAS GOING TO BE
THE NOMINEE.
THEN I WAS SURE SHE WAS GOING TO
BE THE HAVE.
P.
I'M IN THE MEDIA.
THAT WAS THE CHOICE.
WHAT I THOUGHT I SAW OH THIS
PERSON MIGHT BE CHARMING AND
INTERESTING AND TICKS ALL THE
BOXES BUT SHE IS ACTUALLY LIKE
HE THOUGHT SHE COULD BE THE BACK
UP QB BUT SHE IS LIKE THE THIRD
STRING PUNTER.
WHEN SHE SHOWS UP AT THESE
THINGS YOU FEEL LIKE SHE IS IN
OVER HER HEAD IT'S COMPOUNDED BY
THE LAUGHTER AND NERVOUSNESS.
SHE REMINDS ME OF A CO-WORKER
THAT IS NOT UP FOR THE JOB WHEN
YOU ARE IN A MEETING EVERY TIME
HE TALKS OR SHE TALKS IT'S A
CRINGE MOMENT AND THE DOG
BARKINGS MEDIA KNOWS IT TOO.
THEY THOUGHT THIS WAS GOING TO
BE THE NEXT PRESIDENT.
>> Jesse: I THINK EVERYBODY ON
YOUR STAFF KNOWS EXACTLY WHO
THAT EMPLOYEE IS THAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT AT THE MEE